hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in gabriel marcel's essay concrete
approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery there is a brief
discussion
of a term that we translate as
recollection
and its relation with another term that
we
translate as assurance which in the
french is just as
recollection uh hakuyama has
a number of different senses that we're
going to get into in a moment
and interestingly enough in the course
of this
marcel actually brings up the english
expression
to recollect oneself and says that it's
very
revealing and this is important in part
because it's something that marcel
thinks that human beings ought to do
it's a way
of staking oneself onto logically and
existentially but it's also important
for
understanding what he's been laying out
in this the
notion of mystery or meta-problematic
and he tells us that it's rather
difficult
to define and he tells us as well that
this is one reason why
professional philosophers have given
very little attention
to recollection he tells us
why it's difficult to define and then he
provides us with what might be viewed as
his
own attempt at definition of it
he he does also at the very end of this
section of the essay
register a certain annoyance an
annoyance with as he calls it
using abstract language
um when dealing with something that that
isn't quite
so easily approached through the
abstract language and where there's a
danger
of mistaking the terms for the actual
ontological or existential experiences
and realizations he also wants to resist
reducing this just down to
experiences as we're going to see so he
tells us it's most annoying to have to
use such
abstract language when in truth one is
dealing not with
a dialectic odd usum philosophorum that
means
a dialectic for the uses
or customary dealings of philosophers
that is professional philosophers
but with what is most vital and that's
an interesting thing right there we
should pause on that for a second
is this an opposition between the
abstract
you know book bound way of doing things
that philosophers except for maybe
marcel
is engaged with and then we've got life
and vitality
and another kind of philosophy vitalism
over here that's he brings up andre
bergson
of somebody in this essay no
because marcel is going to go beyond
this it isn't just about
life and lived experience versus you
know abstract ideas
he goes on to say with what is most
vital
and i will say most dramatic
drama is incredibly important for marcel
the dramatic dimension
but he also says dramatic in what sense
in the rhythm
of a consciousness seeking to be
conscious of itself to become conscious
of itself which is never something that
is carried out all at once
it's a continual process which has
setbacks and
we might say successes that then have to
be built upon where
a person could take too much from that
success and turn it into something like
a ironclad method and now we're back in
abstract philosophy again
so marcel is saying all of these
reflections about
recollection and assurance
we we have to use the language of
abstract ideas
but we don't want to remain confined to
them we don't want to remain
stuck in them so that said by by way of
preamble what sort of characterization
does he provide well he tells us that it
transcends
a certain dualism he says that it's
difficult to
define if only because recollection
transcends the dualism between an
act and a state of being
so we should talk about that for a
moment what are we what do we mean
a state of being is a way in which
we are something we can describe about
ourselves standing here before you
this is what you know aristotle would
call one of the
accidental predicates right one of the
categories
standing that is uh both an act but it's
also describing the way
in which i are if i if i could say okay
now i'm standing i'm deliberately doing
this
then it becomes an act as opposed to say
leaning
or sitting down or standing on my head
our minds are continually engaged in
acts and we commit ourselves through the
acts we engage in thinking itself
is an act it is not something totally
disconnected
from action or from being that's
something that a lot of people
lose sight of they're like well you're
locked up in your head
you've got all your thoughts none of
them are really real except for you and
then there's the outside world and
that's all these sort of static things
that change every once in a while
and then there's actions between them no
reality is way more complex than that
when we
embrace it in its concrete actuality
actuality is not all act
we can say as well it is also being and
states of being
so there's a dualism here between act
or action and being
and he says that in recollection
these two otherwise opposite aspects
are reconciled and isn't that
interesting a reconciliation is taking
place
that doesn't mean that they simply
become each other you can't reconcile
what
simply fuse or are confused with each
other
they still remain separate things but
they're reconciled
with each other and he goes on to
characterize
uh what recollection means he says the
word itself
says what it means now
it's coming from queer right
uh in it's a gather uh and there's also
acquire to welcome that's that's in the
background i would say
as a french word so
right the action of whenever we have a
re that's always sort of if coming from
latin
an intensification or a duplication
of something and so recollection
implies that there is something to bring
back together again and what are we
bringing back together well
he tells us recollection
is essentially the act whereby
i collect myself
as a unity now that's something very
interesting to think about as well
let's dwell on that sentence for just a
moment the act
whereby i collect myself
as a unity so what was i before a
disunity
we experience that all the time you
walk into a room with the intention of
picking something up and taking it into
the other room
and by the time that you've gotten there
your mind is preoccupied with something
else it could be something you're
thinking about that's on your mind
detaching you from the environment and
your intentionality that you moved in
there
with it could also be you you see you
know something else i'm looking
uh and i see you know candles and books
and thinking
oh maybe i should clean that up right
and now suddenly you are no longer
what you were coming in and there's that
you know that there's something that
you've forgotten you should do
so it's not as if you simply went from
one state
to the other like changing a television
channel where now the signal is totally
different
no there's still this lingering haunting
thing and you're like what did i come in
here for
i mean i know i got to do that thing
over there that's some new information
but what's going on we can also talk
about a person being a disunity
in a moral sense and sometimes this
leads to them repressing things that
they'd
rather not think about or lying to
themselves in all sorts of ways
recollection brings ourselves to
ourselves
in a unity and it's not a completely
stable or static unity
either it is a unity that we then
have to take account of ourselves
and notice you know again what he's said
in there
right i collect myself this is a
reflexive way of speaking
right i i am the subject
collect myself i am also
in a certain sense the object but not
really the object
because i'm not reducible to an object
so there's a complicated action going
on there he also says
very importantly that it's not just
about concentrating
the self it's also about a certain kind
of
letting go he says this is also a
relaxation
it involves abandoning to relaxing in
the presence
of without it being possible for me to
specify in any way the substantive
reality that these
prepositions refer to the path stops he
says in a very nice metaphor
at the threshold so this
is an experience that that many of us
have and if you don't have it it's
you're still doing it
at times as a human being you're just
not aware of it you haven't
recollected your recollection now
he talks about this within a context and
i think going a little bit backwards in
the text
can help us understand why he's bringing
this up
he says that recollection is connected
to the mystery or the meta-problematic
which is one of the main topics of this
entire
essay so if we look at the previous
paragraph before
all of this begins he says the
meta-problematical
is still a content of thought why not
inquire about its motive
existence as such and so why don't we
turn the meta problematical
into a set of ideas that we can explore
and he says
my response to this is as categorical as
can be
to think the meta-problematic is to
affirm
it as indubitably real
as something i cannot doubt without
contradiction now notice he's not saying
i can't doubt it at all i can't engage
in acts of
doubting or skepticism or pessimism or
whatever we want to say
but i can't do so without contradictions
arising
if i really think things through i can't
reduce the meta-problematical
back down to the status of a problem
to be solved something that we can use
techniques upon
and then be done with where we ourselves
are not
directly involved in it he says we are
in a zone where it's impossible to
disassociate the idea itself from the
degree
of certitude it carries this idea
is certitude and here he brings up this
important term again it is assurance
it is its own assurance right
um to that extent he says it's something
other and more than just an
idea we cannot put it at a distance
and grapple with it in a purely abstract
way
or else we lose sight of what it is that
we're actually
working on and our own involvement in it
because
the matter problematic the mystery is
something where not only has
as he tells us earlier it encroaches
upon its own data but we
are existentially involved in it
and so if we lose sight of that we
transform it into something else instead
because of that very feature
of our own involvement our the
inescapability of our involvement
it provides an assurance
another way of translating assurance
guarantee
a vouching for right now that doesn't
mean that we couldn't be
mistaken about things it's not saying we
have reached the
cartesian cogito or something like that
but there is something more going on
here and what allows us to have
that assurance well he says that
a little bit later this is going to tie
in with recollection but he also goes on
and he says
moreover the term content of thought
which figures in the objection is
deceptive
for a content is an extract derived from
experience
whereas only an approach that detaches
or liberates us from the experience
enables us to rise to the level of the
meta-problematical or
of mystery so we're not engaging in
abstraction we're not
extracting something like its essence
we are instead engaging in something
that distances
ourselves from something and at the same
time preserves the closeness
and connection with that thing as well
so he talks about this as a real
disengagement a real disentangling right
a real detachment not an abstraction
what lets us do that this is where we
come to
recollection he says that it is in
recollection
and in recollection alone that this
disengagement
is accomplished so recollection is
something that is
necessary for us to do in order to grasp
individual mysteries which are usually
always connected with other mysteries
right
they're messy they flow into each other
but also to understand the way that the
mysterious or the meta-problematical
works without distorting it into
yet another set of problems that is
why he's looking at this this
idea of recollection
and he goes on and he says that
i'm going to skip over his discussion
about how the psychologist will turn it
into
a problem he tells us that it's in the
womb
of recollection that i take a position
or
more exactly i put myself in a state
that allows me to take a stand
with regard to my life so that's an
important
set of ideas there right it puts me
into a state where i can take a stand
who puts me in that state i put myself
into that state
through in some part my own agency
although of course we're going to find
out that there's other agencies or at
least
instruments involved in the background
it's not totally
up to me right and i put myself into a
state where i can take a stand
another way of talking about this is
taking an existential position
and having a existential realization
so he says i withdraw from it in some
way but not as the pure knowing subject
not a cartesian subject we could say in
this retreat i
bring with me what i am and what my life
perhaps is not
i we perceive the distance between my
being
and my life i am not my life
and if i am able to judge it he says
it's on the condition i can first of all
encounter myself
within recollection that is beyond all
possible judgments and i will add beyond
any possible representation right
he says this process of recollection is
not a
looking at something it is a retrieval a
renewal and somebody might say wow
that's that that's really abstract by
itself
what do all these these terms mean i am
grasping
who i am and what i am and what i am
not and what i you might say
am and am not at the same time
through this this process of
recollection in this
state he talks about encountering
oneself in recollection and here
you know marcelo is very very good about
providing examples throughout most of
his works
he doesn't really provide us a lot of
examples here but we might dwell upon
some
and i invite you to think about your own
experiences that
correspond to this the realization
uh in in having regrets that you
not only did something that maybe wasn't
the best option but seemed to be a good
decision at the time but that you broke
a promise
let somebody down let yourself down
didn't turn out to be the kind of person
that you wanted to be that's that's a
possible experience
of recollection where you take a stand
upon yourself
you are at the same time the person
making the judgment and the person
judged we could also do this with things
where
we're more happy about it right thinking
about our successes
but keeping them within perspective
rather than allow it to
rise to some sort of crazy irrational
elation that now thinks everything in
the world is perfect
right we encounter ourselves we get to
know ourselves better
through recollection we never do so as a
complete totality
there's never a moment of total
enlightenment where now we see
everything
as a whole but we do it over and over
and over again
so he also says well this sounds an
awful lot like
the dialectical moment of turning back
to oneself or the physique sign the
being for oneself that is at the center
of german idealism
now if you're not somebody conversant
with german idealism he's talking about
you know
hegel and other thinkers um
marcel himself was very into the german
idealist when he was a younger person
uh he also read the american idealist
royce and did quite a bit of work on him
and he says no it's not the same thing
as that
why he says entering into oneself does
not mean to be
for oneself and to have in view some
sort of intelligible unity of the
subject and the object
instead we are in the presence of the
paradox of mystery
whereby the self into which i return
ceases
precisely to that extent to belong to
itself so he's not saying here that it's
a matter of
lacking self-consciousness or insight
into the self
he's saying what's missing here is the
idea that the self
doesn't just belong to the self that
it belongs to something else it's
connected
with something and he brings up this uh
phrase coming from saint paul you are
not your own
he says this great statement conveys a
significance that is both ontologically
and essentially
concrete it is what best expresses the
reality we're exploring at the moment
you know sometimes we talk about
something being bigger than ourselves
and us belonging to that and that would
be one modality of that
but it could also be the realization
that one doesn't just belong to oneself
but one also belongs to
beings who are dependent upon one
one's children one's students one's
parents one's
spouse one's neighbors it could be
other things as well these do not
exhaust the possibilities
he also considers whether we should call
this an intuition
and he's he's leery about the word
intuition he says
we have to be extremely prudent if we
can talk about an intuition it's an
intuition
that is not or cannot be given as
such the more that an intuition is
central the more it fills up the depth
of the being
that it illumines the less susceptible
it is to to reflect upon itself or to
apprehend itself this is
this is kind of an issue with intuition
it presents itself and he's not worried
so much about the you know purely
subjective side of intuition
hey what if i have different intuitions
than you he's saying intuition just
doesn't actually reflect on itself
instead it's just bam there it is
and it sort of floods you
that's not what recollection is although
we could certainly have
intuitions within recollection like
wow i really screwed up there that could
be an intuition
right um so he goes on and he says
if we reflect beyond that to ask what an
intuition of being might be
we see that it it it's not uh
susceptible to a figure in a collection
to be catalogued
he goes on and he's got a great metaphor
for this to speak of an
intuition of being is to invite us to
play on a silent piano
isn't that a great turn of phrase
something worth thinking about
what does it mean to play on a silent
piano well there's keys there
and you can play all you want but no
sound comes out
why not maybe the the strings are gone
or maybe it's just a magical piano and
there's nothing to come
out of it intuition and the appeal to
intuition and recollection is is like
that
so he says instead of using the term
intuition we should say instead
we have to deal with an once again
assurance
that underlies the development of
thought all
thought even discursive thought he says
from this it follows we can only
approach it through a
movement of conversion that is to say by
here's a important marcelian term
secondary
reflection that reflection through which
i ask myself in which way
and on what basis the initial process
of reflection was possible which
reflection itself postulated the
ontological but
without realizing it and he says this
second reflection
lets recollection become self-conscious
to the extent that recollection
can be thought what when marcel brings
up this term
secondary reflection anytime that we are
sort of detaching ourselves from
our experience and and being that is
reflection by itself it's usually a
first reflection it's analytic
it breaks things down it it separates
things
secondary reflection reunites it's
synthetic and we are
part of it so we're not just this sort
of sit-back
spirit that's looking at all these
things and putting them back together in
a nice
picture we're in the picture we're part
of the picture
and not just us but in our dramatic
situation which means with other beings
as well which makes it rather messy and
complicated and muddy
but he thinks that this is central to
what real
recollection would be so we have
recollection uh assurance
secondary reflection connected together
these are all things that are not things
but rather
processes or uh
acts states that allow us to apprehend
the
mystery or the meta-problematic as such
you